one problem 70 problem 70 if X plus 5 is
greater than 2 X plus 5 is greater than
2 and X minus 3 X minus 3 is less than 7
the value of x must be between which of
the following pairs of numbers well for
this top one let's just subtract 5 from
both sides of this equation so if you
subtract 5 from both sides you get X is
greater than what's 2 minus 5 X is
greater than minus 3 and let's for this
bottom one let's add 4 to both sides
equation so X minus 3 let's add 3 to
both side of this equation so X minus 3
plus 3 that's X is less than what's 7
plus 3 10 so X is greater than minus 3 I
just wrote this the other way around
and it's less than 10 sorry X is greater
than minus 3 and less than 10 so that's
a problem 71 a gym-class can be divided
into eight teams with an equal number of
players on each team 8 and that means
you get an equal number or into 12 teams
with an equal number on each team 12
teams with an equal number fair enough
what is the lowest possible number of
students in the class so essentially
saying that the number of students in
the class is divisible by both 8 and 12
so what they want to know is what's the
smallest number that's divisible by both
8 and 12 and that's the least common
multiple of 8 and 12 that might ring a
bell for middle school so what's the
smallest number that's divisible by 8
and 12 so let's think of a eights
multiples 8 isn't divisible by 12 16
isn't divisible by 12 what about 24 well
yeah sure 24 is divisible by 12 so the
least common multiple is 24 which is B
and clearly you can divide a gym class
into 2 groups of 8 or sorry 3 groups of
8 or 2 groups of 12 72 72 at least
two-thirds of the 40 members of a
committee must vote in favor
of a resolution for it to pass so at
least two-thirds of 42 pass to pass what
is the greatest number of members who
could vote against the resolution and
still have it pass so essentially
they're saying what is the least number
that we need to have it passed and then
40 - that is the greatest number that
could vote against it so we have to have
at least two-thirds of 40 so what's 2/3
times 40 well that's equal to what 80
over 3 and that's 3 goes into 80 let's
figure it out 3 goes into 8 2 times 2
times 3 is 6
23 times goes into 20 6 times 6 times 3
is 18 then you bring down a 2 we're
going to 0 so it's going to just keep
repeating I say you have to have at
least 26 points 6 people vote for it but
clearly you can't have a point six
person vote for it then 26 people isn't
going to be good enough so you need at
least 27 people at least 27 need to vote
for vote for so 27 are going to vote for
how many going to vote against well that
means let's see 40 minus 27 that means
13 against which is e that is the
greatest number because if if a larger
number voted against it you would have
less people voting for it problem 73 73
in the johnson's monthly budget the
dollar amounts allocated to household
expenses food so i'll say h for
household expenses f for food and
miscellaneous items and miscellaneous
items are in the ratio of 5 to 2 to 1
fair enough respectively if the total
amount allocated to these three
categories is $1,800 so 1800 is the
total what is the amount allocated to
food so we could view it this way if
miscellaneous
so food is going to be twice times
miscellaneous right food is equal to
twice times the miscellaneous and
household items is going to be cool to
five times the miscellaneous so
household items going to be five times
the miscellaneous so we could say that
household plus food plus miscellaneous
it's going to be equal to 1800 and this
ratio tell us that food is two times
miscellaneous household is five times
miscellaneous so let's just substitute
that in five times miscellaneous plus 2
times miscellaneous plus miscellaneous
is equal to 1800 and let's see 5 plus 2
is 7 plus 1 is 8 8 times miscellaneous
is equal to 1800 and so M is equal to
1800 over 8 and let's see what is that
what does that turn into that is equal
to 900 over 4 which is equal to 450 over
2 that's how my brain works have to just
go in steps and what's 450 divided by 2
that's 225
that's miscellaneous they want to know
how much is allocated to food well food
is 2 times miscellaneous right food is 2
times miscellaneous so 2 times 2 25 2
times 2 25 is equal to we're back at 450
and that is choice D problem 74 74 there
are 4 more women than men on Central's
Board of Education so four more women so
women is equal to men plus 4 if there
are 10 members on the board how many are
women so we know that men plus women is
equal to 10 and we want to solve for
women so let's let me solve for men here
then substitute there so you get men is
equal to 10 minus the women we could
substitute that back there we get women
is equal to M or the men which is we
just figured out is 10 minus the women
plus 4 plus 4 sorry plus
for my brain was jumping ahead so let's
add W to both sides so you get to W is
equal to 10 plus 4 which is equal to 14
W is equal to 7 there are seven women on
the board so that's d for all Blom 75
after this one after this video I think
I'm gonna have to call it for a night
and go watch a movie or something
75 Leona bought a one year ten thousand
dollar certificate of deposit that paid
an interest at an annual rate of 8% so
one year ten thousand dollars and it
paid and a rate of 8% of 8% compounded
semi-annually what was the total amount
of interest paid on the certificate at
maturity
so when you say compound semi-annually
that means you collect half of the
interest every half year and that's kind
of that's something I don't know if the
GMAT they should be expecting you to
know that something you probably would
learn in business school but anyway so
after six months after six months you're
going to get you're going to get 4% on
the original amounts you're going to
have 10,000 dollars and you're going to
get 4% of this and so they're going to
owe you - what was the pated compound
settlement what was the total amount of
interest paid on the certificate at
maturity so they're going to pay you ten
thousand ten thousand times half of it
because there's only six months have
gone by eight months is eight percent is
for the full year so for half that
you're going to get times four percent
and then so tenth out you're going to
get ten so let's see ten thousand times
four percent less what is that ten
thousand times for 0.04 let's look at it
this way four times 10,000 is 40,000 we
have two numbers behind the decimal
place so it's four hundred dollars all
right I shouldn't work with this
combinator so it's four hundred dollars
so they're going to pay you $400 and so
then
you can view it essentially they owe you
ten thousand four hundred dollars that's
essentially how much they borrowed you
because they're not going to give it to
you just then you're going to get all
your money back at the end so at the end
they're going to have to pay you another
four percent but this time it's not
going to be all of the ten thousand it's
going to be off of the ten thousand four
hundred dollars so ten thousand four
hundred times 0.04 four times zero zero
two four times zero zero four times four
is 16 4 times 0 0 plus 1 is 1 4 times 1
is 4 and then we have two numbers behind
the decimal point so now they're going
to pay you 416 dollars the second
payment so the total amount what was the
total amount of interest so it's going
to be four hundred sixteen plus four
hundred which is eight hundred and
sixteen dollars right four hundred plus
four sixteen is equal to eight hundred
and sixteen dollars which is choice C
I'm a little surprised that they expect
you to know what compounding
semi-annually means but since they're
it's there I guess you should know it
when they see means compound
semi-annually that means that each stem
semiannual point in time you divide the
annual interest rate by two and you get
that much and then but then the next
interest that you get is off of not just
the initial amount but the initial
amount plus the previous interest
because they haven't paid you yet but
anyway I hope you don't find that too
confusing you might want to look it up
on the internet you could also compound
monthly or daily or continuously
actually have a couple of videos on that
on the Khan Academy but anyway I'm all
out of time so I'll see you in the next
video